Well I think you can really trace it
back to at least the 1960s,
if not earlier.
Well,
what we started to see going on in
American politics in the 1960s and
continuing into the seventies and
eighties was really the disintegration
of the old new deal coalition,
uh,
and alignment that had been,
kind of put together by Franklin
Roosevelt and that sustained the
Democratic Party as the dominant party
in American politics for many years.
Uh,
that coalition consisted of a number of
groups,
uh,
such as white southerners,
northern white ethnic voters,
and white working class voters,
um,
that,
inherently had a little in common with
each other,
particularly when you add in,
um,
the growing representation of African
American voters after the 1960s with the
voting rights act.
Um,
so there's coalition was sort of
inherently unstable.
And what we began to see in the 1960s,
uh,
especially after the passage of the
voting rights act and the growth of the
African American electorate was that,
um,
the more conservative elements in that
coalition,
particularly white southerners,
but also,
um,
conservative white ethnic voters,
uh,
began to move,
towards the Republicans.
Uh,
we had an ideological realignment that
began,
it didn't happen overnight.
It was a,
it was not something that occurred in
the single election or a couple of
elections.
It was something that took place over
several decades,
actually.
Uh,
but we gradually began to see these more
conservative voters moving away from the
Democrats and into the Republican camp.
Uh,
and on the other hand,
in response to that,
um,
more moderate to liberal voters,
uh,
who had been aligned with the
Republicans,
especially in parts of the country where
you had a moderate to liberal
republicans like the northeast,
um,
they began to move away from the
Republicans and toward the Democrats as
the Republican party became increasingly
conservative.
So you can see this beginning with
Richard Nixon southern strategy,
uh,
in 1972,
and continuing with Ronald Reagan's
presidential campaigns.
And then certainly in the 1990s with,
uh,
the,
takeover of the Republican Party in
Congress by I'm more conservative group
of leaders led by Newt Gingrich.
So essentially what was happening here
was that,
uh,
at the elite level,
we were seeing increasing ideological
polarization and that change began to,
uh,
affect the loyalties of the voters,
and increasingly over time.
And by the time we got to the 1990s,
uh,
it had reached the point where,
um,
the,
uh,
old democratic coalition,
and the Democratic dominance of a,
at least congress was no longer no
longer existed.
Uh,
and it's really continued even up to the
present time.
Now,
something else that's been happening a
over this entire time period and
especially with the last couple of
decades,
it's also playing into this has been,
uh,
the demographic changes taking place in
the electric and the growing diversity
of the American Electric,
uh,
where non white voters are becoming a
larger and larger share of the
electorate.
Uh,
and particularly of the Democratic
Coalition,
so that by 2008,
when you look at the contributions of
different racial and ethnic groups to
the party coalitions,
you see that,
um,
nonwhites made up over 40% of democratic
voters.
Um,
whereas,
uh,
non whites were only about seven or 8%
of Republican voters,
you know,
so this is growing divergence between
the parties,
both in terms of their racial and
ethnic,
uh,
groups that support the parties.
And also in terms of ideology and
issues,
it's the more engaged segment of the
public that really becomes increasingly
polarized because they're the ones who
are really following these debates,
who are really attentive to what is
going on in the congress to the
positions of the parties.
Uh,
and so they tend to react much more
quickly than people who are just not,
you know,
not paying attention.
But what happens over time is that even
though this process of realignment
really was,
I think,
initiated by political elites for
strategic reasons.
So you had Republican politicians in
particular who I think saw opportunities
to win over some of these voting groups
that had been traditionally supporting
the Democrats.
Um,
but once the public,
uh,
or at least the attentive segment of the
public becomes polarized,
that in turn sort of starts to constrain
the positions of political elites
themselves.
And now they have to reflect the views
of the voters who make up their,
uh,
their own base.
And so what we're seeing today is that
it's gotten to the point where the party
leaders and candidates for office are
really kind of constrained to a large
degree by the polarization that exists
among the attentive public.
So if you look,
for example,
at primary voters,
you find that,
you know,
Republican primary voters are really
quite conservative.
By enlarge democratic primary voters
tend to be a fairly liberal and
therefore candidates who want to be
successful in politics,
you know,
have to appeal to these primary voters.
In addition,
um,
there are more and more congressional
districts and even states where one
party is dominant and therefore the key
to success in those types of districts.
And those types of states is,
again,
just to appeal to the party base and
there's less need to worry about
appealing to voters,
uh,
from the other party.
So political campaigns have become more
about mobilizing the base then about
appealing to the,
uh,
swing voters in the middle.
Yeah.